first of all let me give a shout out to
somebody that just commented gaucho
argentino he just said i would think pat
would be more punctual than this
listen i'll take the call out buddy i
don't think we've been on time one time
since uh first episode but we are on
episode number 83 today we have tom
zeneron and gerard and at this point if
if tom and gerard go at the pace they're
going they're probably going to
disappear in about 250 days because it
looks like every time i see them they
lose a pound a day they're looking
better and better wow thanks but uh you
look great man thank you seriously
appreciate it so this morning i'm
training with my guy and uh 45 minutes
into it he's the video recording all
this i'm doing all the stuff with him
at 45 minutes he's like how you feeling
us i'm i'm i'm about to throw up i'm
telling you right now he says you want
to stop i said no let's go and we start
going back and forth it was one of the
best trainings i had in a long time had
a really good time that was this morning
that was not today yeah 6am was
fantastic and yesterday
uh shout out to aaron singerman we had a
workout at retcon gym by the way what i
mean that gym is have you been to it oh
my god it's incredible it's like a it's
a great gym i mean it's fantastic
brilliant lighting you never want to go
to any other yeah i just want to be seen
in those right and they're doing a bunch
of different things to it but it was a
good leg workout we did yesterday
and then today we're going to do a
podcast workout you know what you would
enjoy this is so much fun orange theory
workout wearing a mask which is what you
have to do in california so wear a mask
when you work out what do you want to do
that's a one hour very intense you know
cardio weight lifting a one-hour workout
and you have to wear a mask my buddy
today
one of our uh counsels co-founders john
mason he he goes to the dentist
yesterday the dentist says do you have a
mask
he says
you're gonna work on my teeth how are
you gonna work did you see the rules and
the guidelines they just announced in uk
saying you even at bars when you drink
alcohol did you see that or no even at
bars when you drink alcohol you have to
have a mask on yeah they're just going
to keep pushing until we refuse but the
dumbest comedy at that point the dumbest
i've heard yet in jersey at a wrestling
tournament they wouldn't let the kids
shake hands before or after the match
because of stop guidelines stop it
they're wrestling each other oh my god
you can go on not allowed to shake hands
before
or after the match yeah and they've
started the whole thing in new york city
where you have to prove if you're going
to a restaurant that you've been
vaccinated and that's just going to shut
down more you know i love it the little
league dash plays little league in the
summer you know you you're sliding into
guys you know it's intense you're
playing a game for seven innings and
then at the end of the game you can't
shake their hands you gotta wave from
the opposite dugout good game in l.a
yeah how's recall going i saw uh
what's his name meet kevin wasn't
stephen colbert talked about him
yesterday he's catching a woman i'll
tell you what you know the mainstream
media doesn't give anybody any any love
whatsoever you would think larry elder
you know what a great story if you think
about him born and raised in compton a
self-made man african-american
millionaire
just smart achieved so much in his life
built a business uh he gets nothing so
you're gonna have to do it all on your
own but i just think i think he's going
to get recalled i i'm i'm going about 52
to 48 right now that it's going to
happen i just have the ballots yeah i
brought it with me here's the sample
ballot right here me kevin is on here
kevin you know he's really you know
picking up some momentum cnbc did a big
story on him over the weekend i saw that
great story i sent it to him that's a
great story yeah um let me see so where
do i go for the battle it's just like
right right when you get in there oh
really it's two options yes or no so
listen i'm mainly looking for the zen or
last name is what
that's the write-in box john i know
shonda's yeah that's what i'm looking
for well she's satisfied being dictator
of my house
i like that okay so what do i look at
here it's so so they have made this more
complicated
so which of the candidates would go okay
right here yeah so yes or no and then
it's all the candidates so what you're
looking at is the main names are at the
top right so candidates to succeed
governor newsom uh as governor if he is
recalled vote for one michael loebs
party reference none universally
lecturer is who he is
dennis denise lucy teacher
diego martinez then he got a bunch of
different names well he's not on that
list right what's this list that's it's
continued it's that's everybody people
you and you go to second page so larry
elder dennis meet kevin
uh and then john cox is below elder
because most of a person's not gonna go
so how do they do it when it just shows
democrat or republican because that's
some a lot of people would vote i think
so too most of them are republican
there's only a few democrats meet kevin
is maybe one of two democrats harley's
one of them who's running as a democrat
jacqueline mcgowan yeah is running as a
democrat
john drake jeff hewitt running as a
libertarian riverside county supervisor
by the way i interviewed yesterday
uh a doctor what's his last name kai
doctor bear is it bear
who's a full-blown communist professor
at
riverside community college so weird
who's professor to be a communist you
never say that i asked by the way david
did we get a longer than we get along
great you guys got a lot what was
he says look i want to take you out to
dinner and when we go out to dinner i
want to pay for it i'm like you don't
want to pay for it
but i asked him a question it was a very
interesting question you'd be blown away
by his answer he thinks
mao
and he thinks stalin are two of the
greatest leaders of all time okay so i
asked him a question i said let me ask
you this
i said say a 22 year old kid is watching
this interview and me and you are
talking i'm a capitalist you're a
communist he says yes i said this 22
year old kid has to choose he's very
ambitious very driven extremely
motivated he has a choice what's better
to society in the world he chooses to be
the next jeff bezos where in the next 20
years he creates 1.3 million jobs from
america or he chooses to be a
revolutionary leader like stalin who's
better for society he said it's not even
close it's stalin oh my god what
50 million people dead i mean that's
collateral damage i guess what did he
say when i said that he says but that's
part of the sacrifice
that's part of it that's why that's part
of the sacrifice yeah
50 million did make a choice telling you
this was one of the most interesting
energy i can't wait for this thing to
come audience has to see it it was
but the part that you respect about it
was purely shameless like he wasn't a
comedy that's like but no it's noble and
this you know it's so funny i i could
see the two of you guys going out to
dinner he's like no no pat i've got this
i've got this and then going table to
table going like i need ten dollars from
you i need ten dollars the sad thing is
though you you can you can realize what
it is it's folly the guy's crazy but
think about the influence he has on 30
people a day when he's throwing that
message out there to his students it's
unbelievable vulnerable kids at the age
of eighteen nineteen point an
eighteen-year-old with four four yeah
eighteen-year-old would fall for it
everybody's economy until they start
paying taxes yeah
that's right and
anyways it was very interesting by the
way caitlyn jenner is also on the list
but they have her all they have them all
the way at the bottom right all the way
at the bottom so what do you think is
going to end up happening here by the
way you kind of have an idea you kind of
cause it's probably on the news every
day in california yes and no um it's
such propaganda i mean the la times is
fully behind gavin newsom they're making
you feel like you're stupid if you don't
even think anything else all you know so
reid hastings kicked in three million
dollars right to him but that was like
three months yeah but right now you're
seeing that money in action because it's
all used on radio ads radio and
television interesting yeah so every at
the tag of every these every one of
these commercials paid for by reed
hastings by his donation so it's a
constant i mean you listen to the
dodgers game you listen to anything pop
radio boom you're getting those
commercials all the time and it's
basically shaming you in to even think
that you would vote yes on the recall
it's saying it's all driven by right
wing nut jobs and which is not by the
way it's not at all anti-vaxxers things
like that they're throwing the mask
mandate into it at all into as well but
there is no question newsome's nervous
none at all he's he's he's snapping at
press conferences
yes he's snapping about all this i'm
like whoa and that's what happens when
you have a media that just throws you
softballs every single day when they
actually challenge you just a little bit
able to put that video up kai or no
where he's saying uh uh stop bitching
about people are bitching about what's
going on in california you know he's got
that one voice just let me be corrupt my
god how hard is it how much money have i
given you just let me be cool more
handouts you know if the thing that
makes me a little bit nervous is the
mail in ballots you know how those are
going to be counted hopefully
effectively
are you suggesting i'm not suggesting
anything i'm just saying when you mail
that much stuff you're relying on the
u.s postal service and then some minimum
wage workers accountability did you
delete a video that's going viral right
now where people are going around
pulling the recall ballots out did you
see that yeah out of mailboxes right
pretty crazy i want to send it to you
here an airdrop tell me which one to
send it to i i tried explaining this a
couple podcasts ago like uh to adam
exactly like how ballot harvesting works
in big cities and what they do like
literally you put the the ballot boxes
in these giant section eight you know
eight eight-story 10-story developments
and you go door-to-door and you say hey
look sign this sign this sign this sign
this maybe you give them a small
incentive five dollars whatever or you
you look at who they voted for and
you're like i'll take it to older people
they're like i'll take it for you no
problem you clip it open and you're like
oop that guy goes no absolutely not dump
this so they ballot harvest it would
take a team of two people all right
remember we talked about there's two
there's two different moving factors in
politics you have the greedy and you
have the crazy the crazy not the greedy
are the ones on the ground donating
their time spending all day going door
to door so those people aren't playing
it straight those people aren't aren't
here to be civil servants for you
they're here to make sure their side
wins so they're taking these ballots
they're looking at which ballots benefit
them and they're ditching the other ones
man you know the crazy thing is every
name on this ballot you asked them a
year ago this wasn't on their radar
screen the last thing they probably
thought they'd be doing is being the
governor of the fifth biggest economy in
the world i mean if we vote no or yes on
on removing him someone on this list is
going to be the governor and you wonder
how prepared they are how they can
handle that super majority in california
the democrats still have control of
power you know so it's going to be a
tough job whoever gets it but anything
would be better than what we have how is
it not on our phones we can verify
literally everything how is it not
how is what not on our phone voting oh
how is voting not only how is it not
digitized how is it not you you take
like you literally can just facetime in
you see that it's me and i say i just
verbally say who it is that's offensive
though how dare you how how dare you
assume people have other cell phones if
you're watching this just out of
curiosity if you're watching this thumbs
up you want to see this guy be recalled
governor newsom thumbs down just smash
it right there when you see it on your
phone it's not hard you don't need to
type it just press thumbs up i want to
see newsome be recalled thumbs down no i
kind of want to
see him there because i don't think
anybody can do a better job than him i'm
curious kai can you play that video i
just want to show the first 10 seconds
watch this
what the hell
he is going crazy sideways wait wait
wait go back go back you missed it go
back go back a little bit okay go ahead
nice
if our homegrown team start focusing on
what's right
everybody outside this state
is bitching about this state
you should see what he continues saying
by the way we can pause it
he he really loses in this one press
conference by the way it's not it's not
a pretty sight for him yeah he's not
used to being challenged no he's and
that's what happens yeah did you see
biden getting challenged yesterday
yeah
yeah but you know what that was a lot
for george i thought a lot first i
thought it was good i mean just the fact
that he asked him a follow-up question
and pushed him a little bit yeah yeah i
love the guy on brian williams i love
that guy on brian williams you know
brian williams said he teased it up
that's right he teased it up saying you
have to give biden credit right and uh
he he he took it on the chin and he he
claimed responsibility he didn't run
from it and the guy was like uh was i
watching the same thing you guys are
watching
he went off for one minute yeah and it
was a direct call out saying what are
you talking about we told him how to do
it didn't follow anything just decided
to do it on told him this would happen
we begged him not to do that yes and in
the interview with george george says
did you see did you think this was going
to take place yes
were you prepared for this thing yes
would you have done anything differently
no
could you have done anything better no i
mean we can go back and look at it but
no
and then it was pretty yeah
you know i'm not a veteran i wasn't in
the military but i am just disgusted by
what's going on for people that served
over there and served in in the in the
u.s armed forces i mean think about pat
tillman remember when he died and what a
big deal that was in afghanistan detroit
no arizona cardinal he went to asu
straight phoenix all the way and he grew
up in san jose that was
us yeah i know that was friendly fire
but it happened over there and then you
think did everything they do all the
deaths was it for nothing the taliban
was in charge when we came there they're
in charge again now yeah i mean it's
almost like a big uh you know it it's um
i actually i got a bunch of sets it's
interesting you say that time because i
got a bunch of messages i have a few
followers that that are armed forces
people and they're awesome awesome
awesome people my buddy jesse actually
took uh got got shot you know over there
and he he's got he has a tattoo around
the bullet wounds that say infidel but
um
he's a beast but his whole thing was is
like i gotta tell you man 20 years later
do are we more secure or less secure
like serious question and the fact that
you can even debate whether or not we're
more secure or less secure today just
goes to show you the failure and the
waste you know and there was there was
um one guy who messaged me and said man
you know it's it's incredible this
started with americans
jumping out of uh out of the world trade
centers and it ends with afghanis
falling off of airplanes like this is
this is a humanitarian tragedy man like
this is this is something that we're all
going to look at at our
you know while we were complicit and you
know there's a reason why ron paul was
right was trending on twitter all day
yesterday ron paul was right ron paul
you know what you don't like him we you
know you interviewed him you people he's
crazy maybe he's not the best messenger
maybe you don't like his son rand
whatever if you look at what he said for
the last 30 years about american foreign
policy and fiscal policy particularly i
defy anybody to show me where he's been
wrong where he has been the lone person
making sense in our federal government
well i'll add to one thing gerard said
are we safer or less safe
that's an easy answer look at
afghanistan's neighbor china okay so
china has unfettered access into
afghanistan right now and the last thing
too i think biden's messaging is so off
right now he should as the
commander-in-chief and as the president
be emphatic that we're getting everybody
out and and basically their message from
the department of defense is hey if we
can make the deadline you know that that
biden has set and if you can get to the
kabul airport we'll get you out but my
god i i'm assuming special forces are
inside that country right now helping us
and doing it and just doing it under the
radar you know if you're listening to
this and you are either in afghani
yourself okay and you just left you used
to live over there or you're a vet
marine army whatever maybe and you were
in afghanistan you did a tour please
comment below or send us a text to
310-340-1132 can you put that in the
comment section
310-340-1132 again if you're an afghani
who live there or if you're somebody who
served in the military and you were in
afghanistan texas at 310-340-132
and kai try to get some information
about their background once they text
you and find out what their background
is so did you guys see the whole twitter
thing with taliban and trump and all
that kind of trending did you just kind
of see their position why don't we start
with that since we're already on this
topic here and we got a lot of other
things to go through uh just some
stories for folks to know about that
we're going to cover today
is the the elon musk receiving 6.7
billion dollars in compensation in 2020
11 times more than the second highest
paid ceo only fans
grows revenue 553 during pandemic both
tom zenor and g have some comments on
that
daniel craig reveals he will not be
giving his kids an inheritance palantir
a controversial interesting company he
decides to buy 50 million dollars gold
bars what are you doing buying 50
million dollars that's interesting we
will talk about that and a bunch of
other stories that we have here but
let's look at twitter okay let's look at
twitter let's look at twitter so twitter
is apparently
refusing to ban taliban accounts vows to
remain vigilant moderating content this
is a wrap the rap story twitter will
allow taliban affiliated accounts to
continue using its platform despite its
policies against glorification of
violence and threats with the taliban
now regaining control over most of
afghanistan again after the afghan
government collapsed this week social
media companies are now forced to
revisit their policies on pro taliban
accounts either try to recruit new
members from around the globe or
spreading disinformation about the
ongoing civil war a prominent taliban
spokesperson zabi luha mujahid is still
active on the side with over three
hundred thousand followers mujahid was
tweeting as recent as august 17
promoting a press conference unlike its
competitors tik tok and facebook
twitter doesn't have an outright ban on
taliban accounts facebook told cnbc it
will continue to enforce a ban on
taliban accounts that's been in place
for several years and added that it is a
terrorist taliban accounts that's been
in place for uh organization and we have
banned it from our services okay so
that's that part and twitter slammed
after trump is banned but taliban
spokesperson tweets freely uh you know
about the fall of this so what do you
think about this whole position twitter
statement excuse me you know how do you
describe that it's well a lot of layers
here but okay let's talk about the
spokesperson for the taliban all right
so i can't really pronounce his name
effectively but it's zabulaha mujahid i
believe that's who it is and he's
constantly on there
and by the way he's not verified hold on
wait wait
how long how many times did you rehearse
that before you said that you nailed
that on the first try man like seriously
you just got off the plane and you were
like
i hope i was close enough
yeah that was part of my elaborate ruse
to get that name right today flawless
300 000 followers and he's not verified
if you're the person at twitter in
charge of verifying wouldn't you want
the taliban guy not mad at you and you
verify and give him that check mark
right away you know if you watch this if
you peel it back this is a pr campaign
by the taliban to project themselves as
the kinder more gentler
less
oppressive taliban and it's and they're
using it pretty effectively you know
tick tock has banned them facebook has
banned them instagram obviously has
banned them they they don't have a form
but they have one and look at it like
this how has
banning donald trump hurt twitter it has
not hurt them at all their revenue or
their their stock is up 16 this year so
they haven't suffered anything really
from banning trump they're the ones
being talked about right now you know
people are running to twitter to see
what they're saying and and it's working
i think for the taliban i don't think
you want to underestimate what they're
trying to accomplish here and having
what appears to be a willing accomplice
with twitter to let them do it you know
i give you i'll give you a story here
that's that's very um
that's very challenging uh uh to to see
what is the right move to make so in
iran
when khomeini was doing his thinking it
was creating momentum he did it with
tapes
simply tapes like cassette tapes right
and through cassette tapes from france
he kept sending it in from paris because
he was in exile in paris and he kept
sending these tapes and everybody slowly
but surely said did you know what romani
jerusalem did you know what khamenei
said did you work home and he said so
these tapes you burn them and you give
them to other people right
and shah knew this was happening and
shah's concern in iran was more the
two-day party which is a communist party
than khomeini and as people said listen
you got to put a stop to this and there
was a part of shah that said this guy's
never going to have the kind of power to
come and take over
uh iran and iran was becoming a top five
empire worldwide everybody's looking at
him he's negotiating with all the bigger
guys 25-year contract he strikes with
france with uk with us with you know
germany all these guys so he's doing
he's doing the right things
and then all of a sudden one of his
military guys says look i'ma say this to
you one last time we got to take this
guy out we've got to figure he knew
where he was they could get to him they
could do something to him sure to stop
all of this madness he says he's not
going to create that kind of momentum
huh you have two different advisors one
advisor saying don't worry about it it's
not going to create that kind of
momentum another group is saying what we
got to take this guy out what ends up
happening
we know what ends up happening the
regime comes takes over revolution nine
million people revolt over a message
because khomeini kept saying we're gonna
give you free food we're gonna give you
free housing we're to give you free all
this stuff and then iran changes you
know and then now you know what the half
a million people die war iran's you know
iraq all that mess
i think um
that the hardest part like the guy i was
talking to yesterday the communistic
professor right you're like do you allow
a guy like that to teach
is that the biggest threat do you allow
somebody like this to be on twitter
do you allow somebody like this to
recruit younger people who haven't yet
shaped their level of thinking think
about you at 16 years old 17 years old
think about what moved us at 16 17 18
years old how easy easy it was to us for
us to be manipulated by somebody right
some of us are stronger than others but
to allow people like this to be on
twitter i mean what are you doing yeah i
i actually i i think you should but i
you have to make sure if you're going to
allow him to be on twitter you have to
allow somebody else to be you
well fine trump anybody i've been kicked
off twitter four
times taliban's still on there here's a
question though i don't know about that
and here's why
because to me
um uh uh go to your kids let's just say
you got kids you're 45 years old you got
two kids okay gerard uh herron michaels
okay you got two kids
are you okay with your kids kicking it
with anybody
uh
yeah i think so um you sure i i don't
have kids it's hard for me to say okay
are you okay with yourself absolutely
not
because i'm i'm actually opposed to him
hanging out with some of his friends you
know i've identified people that i don't
want him being around why not though
because bad judgment that other person
does stupid things you could be involved
in at what age are you comfortable first
of all you don't have a choice after at
certain age yeah right what age are you
like i can't do nothing about it you
know what i i hope i'll always have the
relationship where i'll have that sway
with them and i know i will but you know
at the age of 21 or 20 or something when
you don't have day-to-day contact or
whatever you're not paying everything
someone's going to be able to go yeah
sure
man if you've raised your kids right
what if your kid can be the positive
influence in that other kid that you
don't like that's not my responsibility
i would i would rather protect him from
something that is not his fault they
can't translate him from ideas no but
that's why it's a wide opening by the
way by the way i agree
okay here's a here's a random question
for you at what age did you see pat
12 okay at what is your juicy pot
maybe 15 because i grew up in the stone
ages okay yeah so i'm the same age 12
13. and what age did you see cocaine
uh 14
18. 18 you saw cocaine right right when
i get to school okay at what age uh did
you
see a you know a person getting freaking
trashed hammered dragged you know like
absolutely lost their minds because how
drunk they were 14 okay yeah late teens
lay teens for some people might be
different because it could be your
parent right because some people tell
you three years old that's all you know
my mom or my dad but i get what you're
saying here but
here's my point to you the point i'm
trying to make to use eventually you're
going to see it yeah how old were you
the first time you saw somebody pull a
gun how old were you first time you saw
a stabbing or have you seen somebody die
have you seen some of that things are
going to happen
but to allow somebody
that is purely about violence gerard
this is not like an opposing idea yeah
there's a big difference between ideas
so so to what do you call it to the shah
he was more worried about the idea of
communism and he was less he was less
worried about a guy that wanted to
revolt and absolutely he killed every
one of his generals sure the khomeini
killed every one of his generals so
which messaging do you have to be more
worried about when you're running a
nation i i need to look i think we
should be ever vigilant and i'm no fan
of the taliban but i also remember the
ira were a terrorist group and now
they're a legitimate political party as
well the ira you know with sin feign are
a legitimate political party and they
were terrorists they absolutely were and
they were murdering terrorists but to
them they were freedom fighters fighting
an oppressive regime uh i'm not pro
taliban and i find i find this world
we're living in so crazy that the week
started with the department of homeland
security essentially describing me as a
terror threat and then i'm listening to
the taliban spokesman what do you mean
describing you well the department of
homeland security
put out a terror threat who who is uh
who is the high terror risk people who
are are skeptical of coveted measures
people who uh uh love america and people
who uh are
use the word patriotic and people who um
uh have deference for the 9 11 holiday
those are all
it was on lester holt so i mean did you
see that yeah i'm so they basically
described me and i'm like holy crap
yeah i'm like what and then that's on
nbc nightly news that's how my week
begins now my week is ending with me
listening to the taliban spokesman
person give american companies a lecture
on free speech and be right about it and
i'm like wait so we started with the
department of homeland security and it
ends with taliban like whoa what message
what what what are you
okay
not like saying is there something for
you to say i don't think that's cool to
allow i think
i think the market of ideas i believe in
humanity i believe in the invisible hand
i think that we don't need laws telling
people not to block the the exit if
there's a fire because there's a fire
people will leave the exit right i i
think that the way you stamp out
extremism is by shining a light on it i
think that you you you don't have to
amplify one voice or another extremism
to me is cancer you talking about
homeani i would have i would have said
take him out i would have said one hunt
and this is a problem i have with with
my libertarian friends and this is where
they get after me i don't believe in the
non-aggression principle i don't i think
counter-punching all the time is stupid
i think some things you have to get in
front of and you can save a lot of
people okay the the
you cannot negotiate a part of that
that's contradictory though isn't it
based on what you're saying because
if that's what you're saying isn't it
isn't it good to get ahead of something
like this isn't it good to get ahead
let's just say this guy that's got 300
000 followers he converts one guy that's
more aspirational than anybody else and
he becomes the next guy that costs a
million lives
but just to complete that thought that's
a great point but you said it yourself
homany was
banned and that made him more popular he
went underground this isn't this
magga isn't gone it's underground
it's not just because
twitter exists because frankly
republicans and conservatives fell
asleep at the wheel and they didn't
compete in tech there's no question and
they didn't compete in education the
fact that that there's nothing there's
no place for these folks to go
it's not the left's fault the left out
competed and they out innovated it's the
wright's fault i don't think that's
i would say this don't underestimate the
taliban this is pure propaganda for them
and and i'm not so worried about one
some an average person falling for this
i'm worried about mainstream media
buying into this crap and then
continuing the narrative that the
taliban has changed and these guys are
smart and let's also remember one thing
they're not a government all right
they are not a government they are
extremists radical muslims that have
taken over a country government is right
now negotiating with the taliban to let
the troops be released u.s is
negotiating with the taliban right now
to allow the uh the translators to be
released i mean u.s is negotiating right
now directly with the taliban yesterday
won the press conferences they asked the
general hey
it sounds like you're negotiating with
the taliban and you're waiting on
taliban to allow you to get the troops
to get out is that true and did you see
what the guy said what it's like uh
uh
jenner milly
jen
you guys gonna see that yeah it was the
most awkward moment yeah like that's
what's happening right now so yeah i
don't know i think
um i think i'm a part of you got to get
ahead of it before it becomes a bigger
problem i'm more from the mindset of
only the paranoid survive and i think
america is not paranoid enough right now
i think america is being a little bit
too
uh uh
trusting and casual and comfortable and
the last time we were like that and
events happen
on 9 11. and i think people have to be a
little bit more paranoid today with
events that are taking place i i that's
that's my mindset so when you hear
something like this hey let's just let
him on there on twitter what more
but think about what but twitter
everybody's talking about twitter every
single day yeah i mean this is they're
probably going to let it ride until they
pull in isis and start showing
decapitations or something and then you
have to get rid of it yeah look i i
to me i i think the the
the marketplace of ideas wins right if
they're out there saying like like what
you said the other day where they're
like we're going to be great with women
and then people on twitter are like see
they've changed and they're like oh cool
so we're going to be great yeah but but
so so i can wear whatever i want
no no no so i mean eventually
so i mean
let's just say what it is so you're
saying kind of like the the propaganda
will mold the the next generation into
being unreasonable is that the idea like
are you do you feel your kid's
generation is going to lack
the the processing skills to be able to
see
extremism for what it is
okay the godfather amazing guy yeah
great guy we're going back and forth
which means we're trying to get a date
phone to come out here to be on the
podcast
but in the interview i said let me ask
you a question do you think the more
shows we have on tv
that show whatever maybe has influence
over kids no i said okay while i'm
talking to i said do you think the more
we see
lgbtq the more we see the nickelodeon
with the trans person coming out and
doing shows on kids do you think that
influences
kids to think they're gay or to want to
be gay he says no i said right well i'm
not maybe you're right maybe you're not
i don't know so i go online and i type
in
the increased percentage of population
being part of the lgbtq community i
don't know if you guys have seen this or
not in the last 30 years it went from
1.1 percent to 2 to 3 to 5
today it's 5.4 percent why is it 5.4
did we all of a sudden have a lot of
people in the lgbtq community last 20
years i don't know is it an influence is
it shows is it tv is it somebody saying
maybe i am it's the questioning right
it's like my friend when we went to the
nightclub at a gay club in in in
tennessee which was the freaking best
club i've ever been in my life it was
like the studio 54 of tennessee
underground place called connections
it was happening if you went there
friday or saturday you had a monopoly
because it was with the bell button
there every night with the bell bottoms
you should see the clothes that was when
my hero was freaking tony monero i mean
that was my hero i was the middle reason
tony monero
and i don't know if you know who tony
monero is saturday night's favorite man
staying alive so so i'd go there and i
would do the whole thing and then one
day one guy comes up to him and he says
hey you know i like you and he
grabs him in the wrong places nowadays a
guy would do time but he might my guy's
like flipping out yeah because he's a
soldier and he says
you ever been with a man before
and he says what
says he says i know you were in the navy
he says no and
he says i like women he says he asked
the question
and he says how do you know you don't
like men if you've never been with one
so now that line has been asked for me
many times because this club i ran the
store sure so i said dude i just know
yeah okay i like girls yeah i can tell
you it's gravity i like girls anyways
so we're driving back it's two o'clock
in the morning no joke it's two o'clock
in the morning
my friend is like bro but how do i know
what is the matter with you buddy
he says but how do i know yeah how do i
know yeah maybe there's only one way to
and i'm like are you seriously doing
this to yourself he says but you know do
you know that was the topic of
discussion you got to know man
we're doing push-ups we're running six
miles he's asking at the end of the chow
hall but i don't know a guy was
conflicted he was comfortable yeah the
point i'm trying to make to you with god
i'm confused now yeah
what's uh
david what
what's part of the hot dog do you like
better the meat of the bun which is the
when you get a hot dog is it the meat or
the bun that looks more appetizing you
know where this goes to you know where
this goes to think about
and and the reason why i'm convinced
with this is the following thing and
i'll bring you to something that's very
familiar to you that's porn
i'm glad you look to your left ah
finally something i know about
so
so uh uh we're trying to one of our
friends one of my friends armenian
friends from glendale uh said you know
what happened with brandi uh lori brown
bernie love she was upset she was a fan
of yours because you defended her and
but she was upset at everybody else but
nikki benz wants to come on okay nicky
benz wants to come and be a guest on
valuetainment so i said okay great so
we're conversation all this stuff
so she wants to be because believe it or
not she's a conservative she's a
conservative okay
so
go back and think about when you're
first time you watch porn so first time
you watch porn uh gerard
six seven i mean what was it for you it
was a sunny
afternoon
a january saturday today do not listen
to today's podcast let me prep you but
do you actually remember how old you
were how old were you the first time
i can be honest with you and you're
gonna think i'm a prude but probably at
a bachelor party for me and i'm not
joking i just didn't have access to yeah
in my 20s yeah uh i could i can tell you
i was i don't know how old i was but i
know i was young enough
that you had to
physically come up and change the
television channels on the tv you were
determined today okay i was a kid by the
way and and i i tried to click the i
tried to click the channels we took
today
we made it it was uh do you remember the
tv for people that for people that don't
know before the internet existed it
would be on tv and it would be like all
blacked out unless you paid for the
channel it would have but you'd see like
little snippets especially there'd be
like little snippets that came out and
then i remember being a kid being like
whoa we're watching what is this
underground porn is what you were
watching was that my answer here's a
question for you here's a question let's
try to get the nickelodeon here's a
question for you question for you did
you watch porn first or did you have sex
first
porn okay all right so watch this so
imagine hard copy by the way like
playboy hard copy pornography i got you
but what i'm saying to you is if you
watched porn before you had sex you were
somewhat messed up oh so you know that
yeah i don't know if you've got it for
sure so do you guys understand where i'm
going 100 man that's what i'm trying to
tell you what i'm trying to tell you is
if you watched porn then you had sex
and let's just say the girl you had sex
with she'd been with others she's like
what the hell is the matter with you i
mean you talk to any marriage counselor
that's destroying marriage that's what
i'm saying so
when does your friend come in do i ask
her i get so many i get questions from
spouses that say hey we have a porn
issue in the family we would like to see
how we can fix this porn issue because
everything is porn and porn is more
exciting than the real thing but men
have this thought pamela anderson talked
about it with her sons she said i had to
tell my boys what the way people have
sex in porn is not how you have sex in
bed that's not what it is so where am i
going with this if porn made young boys
think this is a certain way of having
sex that pleases people just because
it's a video that people are screaming
and then you go in their bedroom they're
like [ __ ] that's the complete maybe some
of the stuff but some of the stuff it's
not
then this goes back to
the taliban how i brought
because it's because the people in
afghanistan are gay
right now
stay with me
how i took this story from a gay club to
porn back to this this is like a biden
speech came to life it's like
hell a lot we're gonna say come on man
the point i'm trying to make to you is
influence influence i'm telling you my
concern is influence you leave people
like this on the wrong person who
doesn't know what's going to say but how
do you know but how do you know but how
do you maybe america does suck maybe we
don't maybe we are the ones that kill
maybe we are a terrible empire maybe we
are that's the part that you have to be
a little bit careful with that's the
part you have to be a little bit curious
there has to be reason again no pat
because people aren't getting on trash
floats and heading into the ocean to
escape people of america people aren't
clinging to their nails
you know what their vision is okay so
what's the kami's vision tell me
communist vision oh man what's communist
vision to eliminate greed to eliminate
billionaires to eliminate the rich to
eliminate the bourgeoisie i think that's
bs i think that their vision is their
self-empowerment under the guise of
humanitarianism
for sure but let me ask you a question
what's a socialist vision i i don't see
any difference between the time they're
slightly different but let's just say
it's pretty close to each other right
that's like 52nd avenue 53rd sure
socialism is just it's just the economic
engine behind capitalism
communism but but the taliban you think
they're you think their vision is
controlling for you think that's what it
is yeah no that's not their reason it's
an interesting thing with the taliban
and all these freedom fighters though
yeah because all they care about is
eliminating authority and then what
happens when all you've done your whole
life is challenge authority and fight
authority then you become the authority
yeah did you see some of the other
images that were out with these guys on
bumper cars and they took over an
amusement park and they were having fun
i mean they're trying to humanize
themselves and i agree people are you
know vulnerable to this messaging
without a doubt and the point i made
earlier too is
once mainstream media starts buying into
it which they probably already are you
know then there's another way you're
going to be subjected to it and you
mention kids i mean kids are getting
bombarded every single direction they go
college you know from professors
hollywood the in in elementary school
right now here's the next thing that
they're going to do the kids they're
going to segregate them on whether
they're wearing it or have been
vaccinated yet and the fda hasn't
approved the vaccine and you're talking
about 12 by the way culver city in la
just uh is the first school district in
la that is mandating that 12 and above
have to be vaccinated to go to school
all right they do that
culver city school district i still work
in coverage yes right by sonya right at
valleys but go ahead so you got to get
vaccinated if you're 12 and not yep to
go to school this year they just came
out with it yesterday yesterday or
tuesday okay i know and it'll fall like
dominoes in the rest of la i guarantee
you here's here's what i'm trying to
like
what's the formula
people come to america for options and
choices how do you lead with force
you know for years we took flu shots and
we took vaccines it was a choice yeah
you took it this is when you do force
it's it's not a marketing strategy
that's effective
plus those vaccines were fda approved i
think you get a lot of people that are
just a little bit afraid of the fact
that it's not fda approved although it
could happen i heard by the end of
august but
yeah that's what kids are dealing with
right well look
to go back and that's that's a whole
nother ball of wax man that the the
segregation that they're doing right now
and the stratifying of society between
the obedient and disobedient is
something that's that's really really
troublesome but look i i have to admit
and i and maybe maybe the reason pat
that i feel the way that i feel about
this is because after 9 11 happened you
gotta you know i grew up in the shadow
of the towers uh i i i
became
there's no other way to say it like
islamophobic i really did i i for a long
time for years after i was one of these
dudes that was like not screw muslims
they're all the same they're this and
that like they they destroyed these
people
and uh dude i was wrong i was young you
know and i was i was flat out wrong so
when it comes to this you know i have to
wonder man like so much of
what's going on in afghanistan is the
fault of our government george bush
dick cheney donald rumsfeld the entire
you know establishment regime for
whatever reason whether it was oil
whether it was access whether it was
poppy whatever reason we were there to
we we weren't there for for the right
reasons and we we destroyed the entire
generation man and
you know this is our cross to bear in
some ways and i'm not look i'm not pro
taliban i got to say that as loud as i
can again but i also don't want to fall
into that same category of we're the
good guys they're the bad guys we're
we're on the side of righteousness
they're on the side you know what we
have to have some enemies right because
right now i mean we do have legit
enemies but no one is hearing about that
and if you're a kid the messaging you're
hearing and if you're a vulnerable
person is the only enemy is someone that
doesn't believe in you in what you
believe politically or maybe socially
that that is the only enemy and that is
the only message these people here we
don't talk about
threats to this country and the legit
enemies that we have i am way more
worried about the fox and the hen house
than i am about the taliban six thousand
miles from me i have to be honest i am
way way way more concerned about ivy
league professors than i am about the
taliban right now i am way way way more
concerned about media executives inside
my own country than i am about the
taliban you're worried about shaping up
the mindset i am you're more worried
about that commie professor than you're
worried about the taliban no doubt about
it no doubt about it so you are the shah
you're thinking like the shot you're
worried about a mindset spreading is
what you're worried about i i am worried
about things that i think that we can
control so here's a question for you i
got a question for you okay historically
do you know how the communist membership
has done have you ever studied how to
communicate
in the united states have you looked at
the numbers yeah what have you noticed
what have you found uh that when times
are bad membership goes up when times
are good membership goes down fraud out
and by the way how bad is a drop-off
when times are good yeah
it's almost to the point where they have
to make times better of course of course
to recruit but when the times are great
what happens to their membership they
fall away they fall away how bad is it
by five percent or like 80 yeah
everybody grows up essentially everybody
grows up 80 okay let me ask you a
question percentage-wise go from 1930
1940 when did karl marx start really
creating momentum what do you what
you're welcome
this is the 19th century but yeah i
would say the bolshevik revolution okay
end of world war one so let's just go
from there let's go 20s yeah okay let's
go 20s 30s to today okay
go 2030 still today
percentage-wise percentage-wise of
communism membership in u.s
is it the same today as it was 90 years
ago
it's an interesting question
percentage-wise yeah i'm not i'm not
talking number i'm asking persons yeah
it's an interesting question i it's
probably lower okay but i think it has
way more people in the mainstream
sympathetic to the idea sympathetic is
different but there are a lot of
sympathetic people you know moms are
sympathetic to but you know it's okay
you know you should forgive him it's
okay it's okay to be sympathetic but the
membership has declined is that a fair
thing i wouldn't think yeah i mean
listen ussr
the actual communist party has now got
an element of capitalism in it it's the
government that's communism that wants
to control the narrative but the
business you can go out and make money
in china yeah it's futile but yeah okay
so so all i'm saying to you is the idea
of communism has gradually lost momentum
is that fair
percentage yes okay so now let me flip
the question on you here's a question
for you
go from
40 years ago 1981
to today
1981 to today
taliban hezbollah extremist any of those
not not muslim the religion that's the
biggest i'm not talking to religion
i'm not talking about the people that
you deal with who are muslim who are
peaceful
loving caring they're just like how you
something how are you a muslim i'm a
muslim i follow some of the stuff that
prophet muhammad talked about
but has the taliban hezbollah isis have
they increased in the last 40 years yes
percentage-wise absolutely is it by
small percentage or by a big percentage
well it's it's by a big percentage and a
lot of that's our doing so what i'm what
i'm saying i i don't disagree
but their number one enemy in the world
is america
because everything america stands for
they don't stand for everything america
stands for they don't stand for they
want to do whatever they can for
everybody who represents the westernized
mindset to be taken off of the face of
the earth anything to do to get rid of
them the point i'm trying to make to you
is the one you're worried about
sometimes
is proven that it doesn't work they're
just a bunch of people that are going
around you know crying whining well it's
not fair let me tell you that with these
capitalists all they want to do is put
people to work and it's like slavery and
it's this this the ultimate slavery is
communism let's face it that's the
ultimate slavery
but the one you have to worry about is
guys like this so for me when they're
okay with them creating this kind of
momentum just look at the percentage of
growth the last 40 years it validates
what we have to really be careful with
they flat out hate you
right they don't not like you they hate
you they want you dead they they wish
you were not here it's a very different
mindset when you think about that
uh are you guys okay if we go to a
softer topic yes pretty seriously for
some time
speaking of bradley let me see what it
does
training there's no chat uh okay uh let
me ask you do we have a phone to make a
call or no i got a guy my sergeant from
the army just texted me from 2012 from
1998 which by the way
did he did he ever find out if
that's crazy if he's listening he
actually went to that club with me but i
i don't
i have a story of his but i'm not going
to tell him maybe he'll tell it but
maybe he's not going to tell it it's a
pretty crazy story but yeah here let me
let me get felix if you're ready i'm
calling you tell me text me and tell me
yes i'll call you if you're ready
freaking wonderful how many times did
this guy scream at you
uh who this guy we're calling oh by the
way let me just tell you like do you
know what his size is
felix
let's see if he's on or listening to
this before i call this guy felix is
oh my gosh felix i got like a billion
stories did you did you say he was like
your corporal or who was your officer i
was i was a a specialist he was a
sergeant and he was uh
the sergeant of supply all right let's
see if we're gonna get a hold of this
guy
let's get this
i'm doing pretty good how about yourself
patrick i am doing good man so what's
the word what are you thinking about
what's going on here with afghanistan
tell us tell the audience who you are
tell our relationship
and give us your idea about what's going
on in afghanistan
you know so patrick you know i i saw
your video and of course like you know
rest of the world i'm sure they're you
know they look at those those videos are
in shock i mean i've had a lot of family
and friends and even people i serve with
you know just kind of give a little bit
of my background you were saying i'm 20
years you know army retired uh i have
five combat tours three of them being in
afghanistan or actually three being in
iraq and one in afghanistan so i spent
over four years of my life you know in
the middle east between between 2003 and
2011. um our relationship you know i
know we me and patrick we served
together back at fort campbell
um you know back in the day and um you
know i remember you telling me stories
about life you know in iran growing up
and so you know as far as you know i
didn't get that perspective of living in
the middle east until of course i spent
you know a good chunk of my life there
and um you know what i see is just
tragic you know it's unfortunate and
like i think i put on your post you know
the fact that
um you know when i hopped on a plane i
remember the colonel briefing us you
know i'm there in the hangar at fort
campbell and it was like how many guys
been to iraq and you know of course i
raised my hand it was my second tour at
the time i did three tours total
and he was like a lot of you think you
might know what you're stepping into but
like when you go to afghanistan it's a
completely different world and i'm like
what's he talking about
and of course he said it's kind of like
the time you know time has stood still
so
um until i was in charge of uh you know
afghanistan detail where i was in charge
of basically ten people we worked at the
entry control points and so you know i i
dealt with them the every day i i fed
them i've trained them and it was just
just blew me away just how far they were
behind to the modern world so felix can
you can you can you paint a picture for
the rest of us
iraq afghanistan so
modernized education
you know
level of lifestyle what it was like
maybe maybe paint a picture for some
that don't know okay so i mean i guess
the best way i can put it is like you
know my parents originally grew up in
mexico right and so when when as an
american i'd go to mexico i would always
be in shock of like it's like a kind of
a second world country you know it's
just not as developed as america the
technology infrastructure
and when i went to i when i went to iraq
you know i kind of identified it as kind
of like i would say let's say like
mexico but as far as just infrastructure
and the people and education you know
but maybe just a little bit behind but
when you go to afghanistan i mean
patrick it's literally like you're going
three thousand years back in time wow i
mean i know there's do people will say
well they see the buildings they see all
that but i'm talking about the everyday
individual the people the farmers the
countrymen the people that are out there
they're just literally behind
the modern world i mean even when i went
to iraq i remember i was in charge of
interpreters so i remember they used to
tell me in iraq now think about this
perspective
that they were shut off to the rest of
the world they weren't able to have uh
uh only certain channels right so saddam
hussein controlled the information flow
that came in there so their perspective
of americans was completely different
until we were there and they saw how
friendly we were how they were there to
help them when they were given that or
they don't even they're shut off to the
rest of the world they don't know what
the rest of the world looks like if that
makes any sense
no of course now felix when you when you
when you so you be in there and amongst
all the other soldiers you're around
officers you're around star majors
you're around first class first
sergeants captains colonels generals
you're on all these guys
behind closed doors when it's just
sitting around shooting you know you're
just having a conversation together what
was the position of most of the soldiers
i'm talking more the leadership not
necessarily
those who are not leading was there is
there position amongst each other why
the hell are we here in the first place
this should have never happened what the
hell are we doing it's a waste of money
you know we could be back it's costing
so many people's lives or was it more
from the standpoint of we got to do our
part to help it's so necessary for us to
be here if we weren't here it'd be such
a [ __ ] show it'd be much worse what was
the language of leaders not victims and
complainers who don't want to be there
who can't wait to come back i'm talking
those who are aspirational leaders at
one they want to move up and the ranks
in the military what was the
conversation behind closed doors i mean
i mean honestly i i really feel that
even as leaders even for for some of the
even the soldiers is like you know
you you you know you might join the
military for different reasons and you
know respect for whatever they join for
but once you go there i mean you're a
human patrick i mean you should know
this right you know you're like wow i i
can't believe people live like this or
they or they have lives like this and so
you know i think overall for a lot the
sentiment is what basically you're
looking for is that we realize that this
is a real problem and the fact that you
know um if we don't change and i think i
send you a text saying that we need to
be there for 100 years and i know of
course that's going to cost the
taxpayers a lot of money i know there's
people that have to go there and serve
but it's not just america's problem it's
the world's problem
got it so felix your position is
that we should have never pulled out of
this last week or you know 10 days ago
we shouldn't have pulled out
i mean from a humanitarian i mean i mean
i mean i'm sure as people look at in awe
right i mean of course i don't
um
you know i don't write the checkbook and
i know that that's a cost to american
taxpayers and and i know there's people
that actually have to go there and serve
it and potentially risk their lives but
i think from a humanitarian effort i
mean you're looking at it that these are
people and individuals like anyone else
until you're there and see it and
realize like how good you have it here
in america
any and you should know that you know
you're telling me the stories of you
know when you used to
get bombed there in iran but it it it is
just completely opposite
out there and it's like you know when
you see the kids and they're just like
you give them
i have a picture and i wish i had it and
this is in iraq so this is back in 2003
when i was convoy back from uh
from being there and i remember stopping
in our convoy like literally like like
five in the morning and some kid ran up
to me and i'm literally like giving and
he was just like can i get like he was
like water water and i gave him a bottle
of water and you thought i would have
given this guy you know this this kid
you know ten thousand dollars i mean
it's just a different mindset until you
have that experience
you know i think it's very moving and
and people i think overall even the
world i mean even as americans i think
we're very empathetic to to people's
causes and of course we want to help a
lot of people and i know it's tough
someone's got to step up but i don't
think it's just america's responsibility
it's the world's responsibility hey
felix oh sorry buddy go ahead this is
tom this is thompson i have a quick
question for you with your perspective
fighting the taliban when you uh were
deployed there a what potential do they
have to actually change do you buy this
that they could be a different version
of the taliban right now and b
what would realistically happen to any
americans or contractors that work for
america as interpreter or anything else
what would happen to them if they were
left behind and not rescued
um i'll be honest i mean they the hatred
you know
from from them is that's all they know
that's all they've been raised on when i
said they have to be there for a hundred
years you have to change a mindset and
that doesn't happen i mean think about i
was there in 2008 to you know uh to 2009
for 13 months and
you know it's just completely different
mindset you have to go in there
and change you know you it's a
generational thing and when i say 100
years these people just think different
well i was i was mainly wondering will
the taliban kill any americans or their
contractors left behind or their lives
in danger if we don't get them out and
do you believe the taliban can change
from my perspective i would say yes
i would say yes they would be because
they were grown to to to hate americans
and they don't know any better i mean
they they think we're there to take the
resources and
and change their way of life and their
ideology and and if they feel that way i
mean they don't they don't think
anything about us you know i mean it's
just they're they're their language of
how they speak
yeah
follow-up question for you here's a
follow-up question for you let's let's
get a little bit more logical so all
this stuff you said i'm fully with you i
totally under i i remember when i got on
the flight to lufthansa flight when i
left iran july 15th of 89 and we crossed
the border and the
flight attendant says if we can
officially serve alcohol everybody
started cheering and clapping because
they finally fell free you did not feel
free until it left the iranian border
that's when we finally felt free so i
understand that part of it but the other
part of it some people may say
well we got 800 military bases in 70
plus countries china's got one military
base by suez canal you know
the djibouti is their base that they
have in djibouti and we got all these
other bases we're spending all this
money we're spending all this taxpayers
money should we go out there and try to
solve every country's problems or should
we let them handle it themselves
i mean to be honest with you if it's if
it's you think it might not be our
problem but if they're harboring you
know terrorism and they they view us as
the enemy i mean just
i mean whether you want to believe it or
not in our eyes we never would have
believed 9 11 would have ever happened
you know and
prior to 9 11 that was unconceivable
patrick but now it's it's it's
conceivable if that makes any sense of
course so
so what i think in my perspective is
that
whether we like it or not
you know and whether what it costs if we
if we ignore that
then what it could potentially harbor
will make
911 be even worse i mean think about
what happened with colvin i mean
god forbid if they were
had the intelligence or had the
technology to do to to harbor
you know biological warfare if anything
the world has taught that that's that's
that's the real threat you know what i'm
saying how do you how strongly do you
feel about our military today like today
how strong do you feel about the
policies we're making today with the
military like do you feel safer today
than you did maybe 10 years ago 20 years
ago tell me about how you're feeling
right now with being safer today than it
was 10 or 20 years ago
you know patrick
that's a great question
i'll share this with you uh my son is
currently in the army my oldest son
matter of fact he's he's he's serving at
fort campbell the place that we serve
together so
um you know i have friends that are
still in and the perspective you know
that i get is that you know um the
military is very dynamic just like it
should be it's constantly changing
sometimes changing for the good
sometimes changing for the bad and just
the direction even when i got out you
know i got out in 2013 when i retired
after 20 years
is that you know that we're trying to be
and this is you know quote me if i'm
crazy if you say that i think we're just
trying to be too
you know overly sensitive
unfortunately the military is is is not
a business it's not a public
organization i think that's how they try
to they're trying to run it today to be
everyone politically correct
um it's it's tough i mean i mean i know
our leaders have a tough job you know
whether that you know i don't want to be
uh
you know uh critical of the
commander-in-chief you know the best you
can do is say hey you know when i was in
the army you know we're going to support
him 100 you know that's that's our job
especially being a leader
and you know um it's
it's it's honestly i think if we don't
if we don't um
if we don't if we ignore that problem it
might not affect us now
but it might affect us 10 years from now
so you think another 911 is eminent and
it just the chances of it increased
yeah uh absolutely increasing i don't
know percentage-wise but i mean yeah i
mean uh i mean look at they they were
waiting they were waiting in the wings
for for years for us to pull out
well felix can i can i uh first of all
what i'm curious about is when are you
running for mayor senate congress
governor when you're running for some
kind of political you know it's a funny
story when i moved to texas
when i moved to texas when i visit you
in california you were hinting about
moving to texas yeah i don't know what
they put in the water here i'll be
honest i absolutely love it here in
texas
um i mean just think about it i
literally
live like probably 15 miles where
tesla's building new factories where are
you you're in austin right if i remember
yeah so if i move for mayor if i if i
run for for political office i think
i'll start off as mayor and then work my
way up well do your thing by that i mean
felix listen you know shit's gonna come
out people are gonna know how hard you
party by the way i don't you can't you
can't hide that stuff because
you know when
can i tell the people a couple stories
about you is that okay patrick
absolutely honestly i'll be honest i
tell stories to you might to my kids and
you know
we went to spring break together but
we'll show that for another for now
which one is that is that is that lavila
is that panama city yeah i i told him i
told him
when you were doing that dance contest
and then all of a sudden yeah you jumped
on the body contest i remember that i
forgot about that one until you brought
it up but we drove and you remember when
we got trophies in your office
what's crazy about this by the way that
club was a legit club club lavilla was
the whole mtv rap all that stuff they
were doing it but we drove this is how
bad the situation was we had a truck
that only
would fit three people
me bradford and felix would sit in the
front in the back for nine hours four
people were sleeping
wow we would drive obviously this stuff
is illegal we don't recommend it kids
please do not do this one of these days
the romney thing that yeah you know that
story's going to come back for us he'll
have a bar man
there is a guy you want to party with
it's felix felix is the guy you want to
party with felix was a guy he would have
25 beers the night before and he would
go out run everybody the next day at
five o'clock in the morning that's
freaking felix
he would run five-minute miles
six-minute miles just piss everybody off
do all the push-ups score perfect pt
score and then out now we'd have 12
beers together by the way felix and i
we watched cocktails together felix how
many times have you watched
the other day dude we watched that thing
probably like a hundred times we watch
cocktails non-stop
and uh there's a certain we watched what
was it cocktails what was the patrick
swayze movie you had roadhouse
we watched roadhouse and there's a few
movies we would watch
and patrick speaking of movies uh i want
to kind of give you uh if you ever want
uh i know you're doing your uh your
mafia
yeah
your mafia movie uh i've got some good
perspective of uh of goodfellas that no
one's ever done before if you ever want
to sit down and do it i'm good with the
autopsy of goodfellas i'm your guy we
will we will i am definitely looking
forward to that one of these days you
got to come out to florida we'll do
something together but felix good to
have you on brother give everybody my
best
you said florida you moved to florida
i'm in florida right i mean i'm in fort
lauderdale right now i don't live in
texas anymore i'm in fort lauderdale
i've been here for
uh what is it now seven months six
months seven months we've been down here
florida well i i definitely know anita
said that she wanted to do with the
valuetainment tour so we'll definitely
uh we'll come out that way to florida
sometime and get the tour and get a
chance to catch up so thank you for uh
having me on the show uh i wish my best
for you and your family and hopefully
we'll have a chance to catch up soon
okay appreciate you buddy take care bye
bye bye what a freaking guy man this guy
he was a pool hustler sick player like
when i took maybe he was the best player
on the entire base out of thirty
thousand soldiers but we'd go two place
here's what this guy would do he's five
six hundred twenty-five pounds felix
we'd go to a uh billiard hall a pool
hall right he would start and he would
start you know
talking trash to everybody and here's
what he would do he would say say
something say something
like challenge him challenge him
i'm on the other side he says say
something you see that guy's my friend
go ahead buddy say and he would fight
everybody and then i'm like felix you're
just trying to hang out man
come on say something watch what's going
to happen we're going to destroy you we
have to let me ask you
when uh it's always awkward man like do
do former veterans do you like when
people like thank you for your service
when they're like thank you for your
service
is it weird you know but i tell you when
somebody does that it's also
you want to be uh appreciated you know
you want somebody to value
uh this is 20 years you're talking about
the one of the stories you didn't talk
about he was in an in a humvee when they
went over and i
i i don't know what it was felix drove
there was like an explosion and he was
in there he saw this stuff so
he messes with you a little bit when you
get out of it right now he's been away
from it for nearly a decade but when you
get out of it at first
it's mentally and emotionally
challenging so yeah but it does uh it's
always great when people say that it's
always great when people say that so
okay so felix that was great let's
continue stories here
uh which one do you want to go to let's
go to to to gerard's favorite story only
fans counter
rose revenue 553
yeah during pandemic and
that's 390 million dollars after
lockdown left consumers looking for
entertainment and out of work
performance looking for a place to
provide report to ft the london-based
platform offers sex workers fitness
influencers and celebrities like rapper
cardi b and avenue to connect directly
with the fans and get paid via
subscription services plus tips its
users base grew from
less than 20 million to
and twenty million over 300 creators
earned more than a million dollars in
2020. wow
but only nsfw
mean
not safe in general
earlier not safe for work earlier this
year subscribers faced backlash after
rapper
bad bad b how do you say that same bad
baby bad baby broke the only fans record
by making a million dollars in less than
six hours after turning 18 only the week
before so yeah that was the whole creepy
thing that that whole thing with her
danielle bregoli bad baby like that's a
weird thing where like she's been hyper
sexualized since she was like 15 years
old and there was like a countdown for
her to turn 18 and all these other
things man that's a whole different king
caboodle uh you know what you know what
i like most about the about porn pat
here we go
is there a long list
all right pbd podcast uh instagram queue
up your short clip the uh
not they they are the most innovative
digital marketplace in the world
everything in the digital marketplace
follows their lead and what you're
seeing here is the future of
entertainment you're seeing personalized
entertainment you're seeing access
people are literally they're not you can
get porn for free everywhere they're not
paying for the nudity they're paying for
the interaction they're paying for
the connection they're paying for the
time feeling special yes this is going
this right here mark my words this is
the future of
sports this is the future of the music
industry there's going to be people who
are paying money to be in the dugout
after a strikeout with a guy you're
gonna you're there's gonna be a an ipad
and i'm gonna be able to curse off mike
stan for blowing uh my fantasy game or
i'm gonna be able to be like mike stan
here's five grand i just i just won uh
10 grand on on the game because that
home run you you hit just put just
locked in the over it's going to be one
on one access it's going to be real time
i was on tour with catfish cooley one of
the coolest dudes ever national
headliner sells out rooms theaters 500
seats 1200 seats his wife has an only
fans account she's very open about it
i'm not breaking any news here she makes
more money on only fans than he does
he's a national headline act he's got
three and a half million followers
she makes more money on her only fans
than he makes as a national headliner so
the marketplace is there this is a proof
of concept for access for all
entertainment uh they only fans said
that they want to get out of the the
pornography game they want to get out of
the not safe for work game i said okay
yeah good luck with that
let's just say they did that what would
happen say they did that
they lose 550 through 52 of their
revenue you know i mean sex still sells
but um listen i think it's been great
for the porn industry i think it's been
great for the porn industry i i used to
do comedy shows with with porn stars and
stuff that's why pat's always always you
know joking like i did comedy shows with
lisa and these other these are decent
human beings man they're human beings
they're sex workers this is how they've
they've all they've all had trauma in
their life they've overcome their trauma
we may not uh agree with their life
decisions but they're they're business
people they are entrepreneurs they're
hard workers and they're fun people man
and
this allows them an opportunity to work
to apply their craft in a safe
environment where they don't have to go
somewhere and you know be in in dude
look at porn the real problem with porn
is the porn industry right less than
outside of the morals like everybody can
have their own you know views on the
morals the industry's scaly as hell this
allows these people to make incredible
amounts of money and avoid all of those
pitfalls now
you talked about this earlier and i'll
leave this up to you because i don't
have kids i i would be very very wary of
snapchat of only fans if i had a 16 17
or 18 year old daughter this would be
like something like that kept me up at
night i'd be like absolutely not let me
let me see your phone let me see your
accounts like you'd have to police the
hell out of that because the
temptation's just too great the
temptation is just there i mean that
like you said this girl danielle bregoli
made a million dollars at 18 years old
but that's she that's who she is for the
rest of her life now right so
and not that there's anything wrong with
that but at the same time it's just like
i don't know like you're gonna want that
for your family you know we'll have a
few kids
um you know talk about a perfect storm i
don't think any company has benefited
more from the pandemic than
only fam or whatever this only fans
because it's not a stock price like
tesla or something
you know
what is this again with the name of this
company um
it's subscribers this is a
subscription-based service and they're
growing and by the way
now we know why no one wants to go to
the office anymore right i mean here's
your answer right here because there's
no such thing as nsfw because nobody
goes to the office they're at home so
this is the perfect storm for them and
they've captured lightning in a bottle
and you know they're pretty smart about
how they do it because it's not complex
and they reward
the entertainers
it's eighty percent they keep eighty
percent brilliant business it's a twenty
percent digital model so this is a
company that tube did two billion in
revenue last year which if you think
about the second largest health club
chain in the country lifetime fitness
that's about what they do in revenue two
billion you know with 250 locations this
is easily scalable though this is a
business model that's scalable yeah of
course um so 300 people became how many
of the 300 millionaires are in the porn
industry do you think probably 95 of
them no i don't think so i think it's i
think it's probably going to be let's
see but by the way let's let's let's
know
i worked in chatsworth valleys for a
while chatsworth at one point eighty
percent of all the porn was produced in
chatsworth california
a lot of our members were porn stars
late at night when i would close this
yeah right by van nuys at midnight when
i would close the gym they would always
come and say hey mum if we because we
were the only one that had an outdoor
pool it's like you mind if we just kick
it outside and i'm like listen guys kick
it fine anything like that you can't
because i'm going to get in trouble so i
would stay with them for an hour but the
life is not the ju you just
we're not here glorifying the life the
life
that world to go into that world you
have to have a pretty rough life to want
to go into that world that's not there
is issues upbringing family parents
father mother there's a lot of issues
there before you get into it for every
one story it's like oh ever since i was
a kid i wanted to you don't hear those
steps
there's a few industries you don't hear
one you don't hear somebody saying ever
since i was a kid i wanted to go into
porn ever since i was a kid i wanted to
go into you know
this industry it happens because of
desperation many times and the money can
be good now uh uh drugs alcohol all of
that stuff
it's a it's a messy industry to be a
part of but it is what it is and there's
a market for it right so
uh
can they change their model and get away
with it no am i surprised that they grew
553 no uh could that have been a
thousand percent yes 300 people making a
million dollars is that attractive to a
lot of people yes could this be a model
that's going to continue to grow for a
long time to come i don't think it's
going to go away let me let me ask you
do you think instagram would be where it
is today if it wasn't for girls with uh
thongs
on taking pictures every day or you know
girls with with the stringiest of
bikinis that that doesn't seem to bother
people morally you're an influencer
you're a model but then if you just take
off that little piece of string now all
of a sudden you're immoral like i i i
have a tough time with with that like
you're an instagram model you're an
influencer calvin klein will give you
ten thousand dollars to do a spot right
chloe chloe jenner can do whatever she
wants and also i think kim kardashian
kind of changed all this stuff kim
kardashian did porn to get famous
she all but admits it now that that it
was the mother's idea to put out this
porn tape so that she was no longer
paris hilton's closet organizer now she
becomes this international brand and how
many other people have done the same
thing the teen mom this and that it was
like porn was something that oh my god i
can't believe this happened with pamela
anderson and tommy lee now it's
something people do to like jump start
putting you on the map you know nuts it
gets the attention by the way they don't
have an app yet right so this is all
just online do you think if they get an
app that makes it you know grow man
that's crazy so
you're gonna be sitting on the subway in
new york and someone's got their phone
out with their only fans has got to get
it in like all right let's go to the
next story let's go to the next story
let's go to daniel craig reveals he
won't be leaving his kids any
inheritance okay so daniel craig who's
who he's a double or seven he's james
bond right good looking guy rock star
absolute stead of a guy says he will not
be leaving his kids any money to his
children from his inheritance the 53
year old james bond star was asked about
leaving his two daughters money and said
isn't there an old adage that if you die
a rich person you fail daniel continued
in his quote to candice magazine i think
andrew carnegie and american industrials
gave away what in today's money would
have been 11 billion dollars which shows
how rich he was because i'll bet he kept
some of it too he added but i don't want
to leave great sums to the next
generation i think inheritance is quite
distasteful my philosophy is get rid of
it or give it away before you go
thoughts i'll give you i had two
thoughts and two questions when i first
heard about this story number one how
much is daniel craig worth all right
he's done five bond movies he's gonna do
one more he's worth 160 million so we
are talking about a significant amount
of money here that could be passed on
here's my second question and i
legitimately came up with this and it's
this how much does he hate his kids
because he clearly does i mean yes
you have to dislike your children to not
want to give them part of what you've
earned and i and i will not waver from
that now so
he was married in the 90s and so he's
got a child that's 29 now a daughter i
think her name is fiona okay so he's got
a daughter with rachel uh weiss no that
he's got a young child with rachel weiss
okay kids that's pretty solid i mean
that's well i'm going to stay with this
okay let's let's okay so then he
he also has a stepchild that's 15. and
my thought is does that step child annoy
you so much that you don't want to pass
on some money i don't get it i think
there has to be some rationale by the
way he's trying to justify this quote
isn't there an old adage that if you die
a rich person you failed no there isn't
i've never heard that in my life and i
think you just made that up daniel craig
i don't believe that is an old adage so
i think you have to get to the root of
this if you dive deep and try to figure
this out on a psychological basis with
daniel craig i think he has a dislike
for his children or one of them and he
doesn't want to give him any money i
will i will see daniel craig's quotes
and i will i will match him and raise
him a famous british soccer player named
george best has the greatest quote about
dying with money of all time he's on his
deathbed and he had spent uh for people
that don't know he was he was a british
playboy and and you know he was known
for lavish parties and and being a
swinger and stuff like that and he's
sitting there on his deathbed and he
goes uh
of my money i spent on fast cars and
faster women and the other 10 i wasted
and you know what hey man it's your
money do what you want with it but i
will say this okay and this goes back to
uh when i was coaching and i was
coaching young kids and i i was always
fascinated by
how different the kids the wealthy kids
were than their parents especially the
hard-working parents like dudes that
were contractors and stuff like that and
masons who had really really made a life
for themselves and then their kids were
like pretty soft man and and i i one day
i i asked him i asked this one dude i'm
not gonna say his name and i was like
dude you are the toughest dude i've ever
met in my life like you've got rock
hands like i ask your kids to do 10
push-ups and they cry like
what happened here man he goes it's my
wife dude he's like when you he's like
you'll see one day if you have money you
give your kids everything you never had
and they will turn into everything you
never were and that's
that's kind of uh his his uh you know
his mason philosophy man look that's not
universal but i think there's something
to it like i think there's i don't i
don't think daniel craig is gonna follow
through with it but i think there's
something to the salvo of making his
kids go hey you better work i this i'm
not i'm not going to leave you this i'm
not going to leave you this life maybe
he will maybe he won't but that that to
me is a message to his kids going you
guys better get to it yeah you know i
just pulled up right now uh an article
from cnbc billionaires who said they're
not leaving their kids their fortunes
okay so you got zuckerberg at the top
then you have bill gates who said
uh it will mean they will have to find a
way
uh on their own and he says it it's not
a favor to kids to have them have huge
sums of wealth
uh it distorts anything they might do
creating their own path chuck feeney
same thing
warren buffett same thing
enough money so they will they would
feel they could do anything but not much
that they could do nothing
michael bloomberg same thing
he said if you want to do something for
your children and show how much you love
them the single best thing by far is to
support organization that will create a
better world for them and their children
so not giving them the money that's
difficult only there was somebody maybe
in the room who had accumulated vast
sums of money and had children that
maybe could have an opinion on this so
you know you know what i would say about
this here's what i would say here's what
i would say about this i don't know who
we had on recently kai maybe you'll
remember this with your memory where he
said tell me who's uh
carnegie's uh great great great grandson
right now that we all know about
tell me who is it tell me who is the
current vanderbilt billionaire that the
money got uh given to that we know
interesting
tell me who is the current you know
rockefeller that's a great ma you know
interesting first so tell me tell me the
richest man's great great grandkids that
still have the money tell me you ever
met anybody named medici yeah so
interesting so i interviewed a guy i
don't know what his name was but i
interviewed a guy from seattle do you
remember his name the guy from seattle
who was dealing with all the
billionaires in seattle and his job was
family planning
and one of the families he dealt with
was uh this big fund uh templeton
franklin templeton fund he the the owner
was worth five billion dollars mark
demos mark demos right and his job was
to prevent these kids from committing
suicide becoming drug dealers killing
becoming drug addicts drinking alcohol
and pretty much killing themselves and
wasting their lives because these
billionaires went out there made all the
money gave their kids everything they
wanted made their lives easy and they
screwed their whole things up this right
here takes me back to a book i read
years ago by jim stovall called the
ultimate gift i don't know if you've
read it or not i probably bought a few
thousand copies and i always have my
guys read it jim stovall on the move the
whole story is about a guy named red
stevens he's from a very low-income
family simple guy comes he starts
working for this one guy in texas
apparently i think
and the guy who he's working for
dies and leaves him with his land well
the guy takes the land they strike oil
apparently there's a bunch of oil at
this place well he becomes a billionaire
rhett stevens after he becomes a
billionaire his best friend becomes his
lawyer
he sits his lawyer down and he tells us
lauren they record 13 videos is what he
records the one video he records is the
day when he dies okay and that video is
going to be watched by all his family
members a fascinating story so the day
comes when he dies he's worth two and a
half billion dollars
everybody shows up his wife shows up
with two of his young boyfriends okay
his kid shows up his nephew shows up his
daughter shows up everybody shows up and
he plays the video he says well
if you're watching this video it's
because i'm dead okay
now
there's a few things by the way do you
guys hear that background noise the
music i don't know what that is kai is
it you
is it the phone oh it's the phone
somebody keeps calling it i got it so he
says uh so he says uh
so if you're watching this video it's
because i'm dead great he says well let
me start off by saying that my son i
love you you're amazing you're great
you're gonna get the 620 million dollars
of money under management and everything
we do he starts celebrating with his
girlfriends he said well here's a
problem
you have no say in it
you're going to get a small interest
that's going to be given to you the
money manager i trust manages the whole
thing now you
pissed off gets up walks out
honey i love you you're gonna get a real
estate portfolio worth 600 million
dollars and the young boyfriends all
this stuff
but you have no say the janitors have
more to say than you do you just get to
live there you don't make the decisions
and he goes around everybody and he
makes these types of decisions at the
end he says there's only one of you here
that i have the ultimate gift for and
it's my nephew for you i have the
ultimate gift i don't have cars i don't
have a house i don't have investment
portfolio i don't have a company to give
you i have no dollar to give you but i
have the ultimate gift you could get the
ultimate gift but it's going to take you
12 months to receive the ultimate gift
if you want the ultimate gift come back
here on tuesday to meet with my best
friend my lawyer and he's going to tell
you what the ultimate gift is everybody
else you're dismissed the nephew gets up
cursing him out i knew he was cheap he
wasn't gonna do [ __ ] for me all this
other stuff
and the uncle says he says you were the
only one
i didn't do everything for and i didn't
buy everything you're the only one i can
save everybody else i gave you way too
much and you don't appreciate any of it
nephew leaves comes back on tuesday and
they sit down and it goes through the
ultimate gift and the whole process by
learning about hard work learning about
giving back learning about teamwork
learning about all this other stuff
there's a portion of this message that
makes sense okay
but i think you as a parent can create a
compensation plan for your kids and the
compensation plan can be based on bogies
you hit what are the bogies you hit well
trump said three things i i want from
you no drugs no alcohol no tattoos you
do that i'll back you up now you may
agree you may not agree that's his three
right don jr did some of that stuff when
he was in college but still supporting
him right you may sit there and say well
here's what you have when you get out of
high school like last time my kids were
talking mario was sitting right next to
me i'm like hey
what are you going to do when you
graduate high school
dylan's like i don't know that i don't
know if i'm going to go to college why
not
because i'm going to go to college and
all of a sudden they started bringing a
boarding school because a private school
they're going to there's a boarding
school company i don't ever want to go
to boarding school why because i want to
live with that so how long do you want
to live with me forever dylan you want
to live me forever i want to live with
you for dylan you're not going to want
to i promise you're not going to
i want you to leave me for you you don't
wanna live with me forever
yeah he likes the house a lot
moral the story is they said so what are
we gonna do i said well look that is
gonna leave you a portion of money that
you can choose to use for a couple
different criterias you decide what you
want to do with this money but if you
screw it up you don't get anything else
that's all the money you got so you
better use it wisely i think these are
times that parents
don't create a set of criterias for
their kids everything comes becomes
about giving it to him if you do that
and you're not there i was watching one
of these roast videos yeah where alec
baldwin's daughter
says oh you guys know who i am here's
who i am ireland i am the yeah i am the
daughter of such and such man and i got
to tell you you know him from this movie
you know him from that movie you know
him from this but what i know him from
is he showed up about to half of my
birthdays over the last 30 years
exactly and he doesn't laugh yeah huh
and he doesn't laugh so so if you're the
guy that makes the money
and you're not there at those birthday
parties and you're doing movies six
months out you're in europe
it's a part of that that kind of screw
the whole thing this is an indictment on
these rich people all right it's so easy
for them at the end of the road saying
i'm not gonna give you anything but
where were you raising those kids the
reason you haven't heard about them is
because they the these parents ignored
them forever and just gave them
everything i 100 blame them if their
kids turn into train wrecks and they end
up giving them all the money and daniel
craig i stand by my statement that you
just don't like your kids i i just
there has to be a component of that in
there how would you not want to take
care of your kids all right i don't get
it so what a sport i just hope he keeps
making movies man i just want to love
him
pierce brosnan was the best bond was he
i think
he's pretty good i think so irish too
pretty good good looking material to
work with so so basically all right so
if i ever have wealth what i'm getting
out of this is that i
if i want my kids to have it they need
to be worthy of it so i'm gonna have to
create like some sort of
legend of uh the hidden temple temple of
doom they have to be able to like get
through certain different levels of
security and then once they prove
themselves worthy of the wealth maybe
tame a lion i don't know something like
that is that like but you're going to
tell your kids at a young age so they
know what they're striving for right you
know you know kind of like the whole
thing well you're worth 100 million
dollars you die you leave each kid 25
million dollars because you're doing the
math it's not going to be me yeah your
boy robert kiyosaki man he uh he was
asked once about generational wealth and
it was uh some social is like don't you
think generational wealth is it the
compound interest and it's it's one of
the uh this it's basically royalty and
he was like uh no it's it
most wealth is gone by the third
generation there's like a third
generation
yeah it's all gone by the third
generation so the habits is what you
want to pass down i'm not worried about
passing down the money yeah i want to
pass down the habits to you i picked up
my dad's habit of working hard that's
what i picked up i picked up math for my
mom i picked up an analytics that's what
was passed down my my parents they had
no money nothing was passed down to me
financially that's what i picked up now
here's the other part say your parents
are billionaires can you pass it down
this is the question i have sorry can
you pass it down without that
desperation your father had desperation
you had desperation right so there's
passed down desperation and you can't
pass down desperation you cannot pass
them so it's going to thrive in their
dna and they should be fostered
in your dna but for every steph curry
there's you know no no i don't disagree
with you you cannot pass on desperation
there's got to be a part for them too
but if you
become look this lady at nordstrom's man
like completely broke down parenting to
me in 30 seconds
i'm in nordstrom's dylan's on top of me
i'm in the room i'm changing i'm waiting
for the next room to be open it's packed
dylan's wrestling on top of me i'm you
know we're always wrestling together he
always wants to wrestle me right he's on
top of my head and i was like you know
he got me in the chokehold and this
lady's like wow you know i remember
those days i said what days my son is 40
right now but i remember when he was 5.
i said really i said give me three tips
on parenting i always ask that question
so give me three tips i'm not gonna give
you three but i'll give you one so
what's that says you know you when you
threat your kids
that if they do something you're gonna
take something away from them
i said yes always keep your commitment
what a freaking advice
did you get it yeah if you tell them
yeah you're not going to get ice cream
don't bluff them yeah because you will
lose credibility if you tell them
they're not going to get ice cream don't
give them the ice cream yeah right
that's the one of the biggest things
when you see with parenting his parents
are like but it's my daughter and i want
to do for but it's my son
it's very true it only took it only took
one time for me to get the belt and then
i knew my father would actually give me
the period their intake is very
complicated it ain't easy and for
parents out there that do their best
look perfection is not the standard
because you're going to screw up you
just want to be able to do your best and
not screw up your kids too much next
story palantir by 50 million dollars in
gourd gold bars in august
as cash pile grows so this is a cnbc
story while some companies such as tesla
are diversifying into bitcoin data
analytics software company palantirs
betting on gold volunteer about 50
million dollars in gold bars in august
the company disclosed in its latest
earnings statement the move reflects a
growing company stashing cash in an
unconventional asset in response to
economic uncertainty spurred by the
coronavirus pandemic in government's
response to the price of an ounce of
gold crossed two thousand dollars mark
for the first time last year as a
pandemic worsened and us government
stimulus efforts continued the years
this year's investors have more loudly
voiced concerns about inflation and gold
is sometimes viewed as a hedge against
inflation although prices are down seven
percent for the year some investors have
thought cryptocurrency might also serve
that role thoughts ah this scares the
living hell out of me because when you
say paluntir yeah it's really peter
thiel who's one of the most brilliant
investors of all time libertarian guys
yes um
they
are doing this for what they say uh in
the in the event of a black swan uh
event uh a global catastrophe they're
also uh for the record they are
incredibly bullish on on bitcoin and
crypto as well but
this is why it scares me because peter
thiel is almost never wrong he's always
ahead of trend and palantir specifically
exists for one reason they are a
predictive analytics fund that helps uh
governments and fortune 100 companies
be ready for the future so if their
predictive analytics are saying we need
to stockpile resources in event of this
global catastrophe that scares the hell
out of me because that's not your crazy
uncle with a tin foil hat that's
somebody that's been proven right again
and again and again well i will say this
i think it's there's a
companies are hoarding cash right now
that we did a story yesterday on
vtpost.com the top six largest companies
in the world that aren't financial firms
are sitting on seven trillion in cash
right now so that there it has to be put
somewhere and i'm just wondering a
is 50 bill how much is 50 million is 50
million really that much compared to how
much cash they probably questions
50 million in gold though yeah but i
think it's just another angle they put
it in and but that's 50 million today
though tom like that that is a set asset
amount that 50 million in gold could
very well be 500 million in gold
the same amount could appreciate it's
true now gold is down right a little bit
this year seven percent i think it's
down for the year but it's always going
to have value it's going to go up and
down and it won't be a bad investment
but my initial thought was they're
sitting on billions and 50 million is
just what they put into one aspect of it
and it gets a lot of publicity because
it sounds like a lot and then were they
gonna store it i heard somewhere are
they gonna store it somewhere in the
northeast i'm not nervous about storing
gold yeah if they if they tell us david
yeah right we should go yeah well let's
look at this kai can you find out how
much cash is does palantir sit on right
now right there okay uh as of march 31st
of 2021 they're sitting on 2.38 billion
dollars so 2.83 2.38 billion dollars if
we do
uh
uh two points let's do the math here
50 million
divided by
2.8 uh two point three eight
billion let's take a look at this what
this percentage is
it's really point zero two percent it's
nothing they're just diversifying it's
not uh
if it was ten percent if it was twenty
percent that's legit if you're doing
point zero two percent it's kinda like
you got a million dollars like yeah the
advisor says i think you should put
fifty thousand dollars in uh you know uh
what do you call it precious metals okay
cool let's do fifty thousand dollars i
think that's kind of what the
positioning is
i don't see it as anything more than
that gold quite frankly i have gold uh
and i have crypto and gold doesn't come
anywhere near what uh crypto has done
but the purpose of buying gold is very
different than the purpose of buying
investment stocks or crypto it's a very
different philosophy of why you buy gold
gold
gold if we ever go gold standard what's
the likelihood of us ever going back to
gold standard zero it's it's like point
zero zero zero zero one percent right
okay so they say well if we go back to
gold standard like you know
it's gonna go from two thousand to half
a million dollars come on now you you
sound like the same guy that says
bitcoin is gonna go to a million by the
end of the year right it's the same
exact uh uh uh marketing strategy that
people are using but this is simply i
think you ought to have a small
percentage of money in gold and uh
precious metals and that's probably what
these guys are doing i don't think it's
anything more than that uh next story
elon musk 6.7 billion in compensation
last year uh let me
say that one more time elon musk is comp
last year was 6.7 billion dollars
that's 11 times more than the second
highest-paid ceo this is a business
insider story tesla's self-styled tekken
inc received 6.66 billion dollars in
compensation 2020 nearly 12 times that i
don't know pay index musk hasn't
received his billions in cash his
compensation was comprised of option
awards giving him the right to acquire
tesla shares at a set price 2020 second
highest paid executive was mike
uh piak kos
ceo of oak street health who received
568 million dollars the top 10 features
executives from seven different
companies and it's entirely comprised of
men
versus good rx uh good prescription
holding kosio trevor and douglas they
were at 497 million dollars a bunch of
different names you see on the list that
you're not going to know many of these
names by the way but musk 6.66 billion
too much money too little money or about
the right number my first reaction is
holy crap that seems really low to me i
mean we are talking about a guy who
started the company who runs the company
who is the face of the company star
tesla though
like i said before you interrupted me
we're talking about guy that runs the
company that is the face of the company
and that basically saved the company hey
look it's all tied to performance all
right they had a great year i don't see
how this is out of line at all he took
zero in cash and people want to lump him
in with the ceo overpay narrative i
think it's actually the opposite i mean
i think he should be a commended for it
he made thousands of people rich last
year the stock price went from ninety
dollars at the beginning of the year to
seven hundred dollars he lives in a
glorified shack right a fifty thousand
dollar little thing prefab thing that he
lives in it's not like he's flaunting
his wealth
you know he used to take a salary his
salary was 23 000 in 2019 56 000 in
2018. so
i think he should be applauded i think
this is a great story where someone is
tied to revenues of the company and 6.6
b sounds about right i'm so sick of
counting other people's money man like i
really am like what does it matter to
you like people somehow they view this
as like it's one one pie like like our
economy is just one big old pizza pie
and this dude's taking giant slices so
none of us have any more
his the food he eats doesn't make you
[ __ ] man like who cares like it's a
great story good for him i'm a tesla
shareholder it's been awesome for me man
i love the guy but i don't care i don't
care how much athletes make i don't care
how much owners make i don't care how
much anybody else makes it doesn't
bother me it doesn't interest me dude
what are you making you want that money
go make something what are you making
man like i don't care like these people
are like how dare this guy make this
much money i always go back to that old
quote and this is not a new thing this
was there was some activist commie
freaking journalist a hundred years ago
asking babe ruth don't you think it's
outrageous that you make you make more
money than the president united states
and bay ruth without even skipping a b
goes i had a better year
you know what i mean like yeah 100k
that's what you did
i had a better you made more money than
herbert humphrey i had a better year
yeah dude like come on man who cares
like like is he taking away from people
is he taking away like what is he doing
he's creating jobs he's he's creating
what you can't make these people happy
there's nothing you can do
to make these people make
hey what's
is he is he doing it through oil is he
doing it through fossil fuels he's
saving the universe he's saving the
environment he's gonna he's gonna
colonize mars who cares now the one
thing i do get pissy okay here you go
you want me to get pissy at elon musk
what the hell does he need seven billion
dollars of taxpayer money for with nasa
what's he need that for that i'll get
pissy with i'll get pissy with him and
bezos going back and forth with nasa
over oh no i deserve the six million
dollars no i deserve why don't you guys
pay for it well that's the most a
separate company though right that isn't
doing as well as tesla sure spacex fine
whatever cuz you know you could call it
whatever you want to call it but
look
they don't need our money that you want
me to get pissy i'll get pissy about
that all right but that he makes his own
money in the private sector god bless
bro who cares
that's your position as well you're fine
with that with him making that kind of
money i have no problem with it well
listen kudos to elon musk he had a
killer year
and uh guy's now worth what a couple
hundred billion is he had a couple
hundred yeah no no no he's he's a 150.
buck fifty what is the matter with him
like what's your weight how does he
pronounce his son's name or daughter's
name oh i know that is gina what was
this oh it's crazy
is it really kidding i think he said it
was pronounced sasha sasha and is he
going to leave anybody even though it's
like
yeah yeah it's like sasha what what is
what is elon's long-term aspiration do
you think he's long-term forever it is
do you think that's what it is
people on
the elites the global elites right i
think the new thing is longevity they
want to live to 200 300 400 years old
i think they already um automatically
assume that they're going to get close
to that but i think his
i think what drives him is to get tesla
fixed so he can get out of there somehow
find a way to exit and just concentrate
on putting people on mars digital do you
think we're going to get to a point
where people could live 200 300 years no
no no i don't think we'll see it i mean
could it eventually happen what would
you define life as
yeah right what would you define like
dead
seriously what do you think we're going
to get to people yeah like what like 300
years well you'd have you'd have to
define life like if they could upload
your consciousness into some
you know uh if they could somehow you
know
data map your consciousness and upload
it into you know some sort of matrix and
you can theoretically i don't know
about that live forever i mean is that
life i mean i we'd have to redefine what
life is
you're said in an interview that that's
what he wants is eventually technically
you could put your consciousness in like
a computer and live forever i i i did a
cs lewis you had me reading c.s lewis
the other day and i saw an unbelievable
c.s lewis quote and i said you you are
you do not have a soul you are a soul
you have a body this is just a spacesuit
this is a spacesuit man like all we are
is this is a this is a containment for
the biofuels
you know so
yeah like if they if they could isolate
the soul what's this what's the say i
mean if you're religious you think you
live forever anyway right on a different
you know spiritual plane but you know
what i think longevity is the goal i
really do i think that everything that
they're doing uh is for them to be able
to to
sustain their lifestyle forever and i
will answer this i i do believe that we
could see people living to be 150 and
above and just look at
just look at what we're already
witnessing look at tom brady who looks
like he's 30 who's playing like he's 32
there's no indication that he's done in
one or two or three years and he's 44
years old right now and before that i
mean think about george blanda right he
was the first nfl player to play at the
age of 40. he looked like he was 63. you
know and he felt like he was 80. yeah
brady so if we're seeing this type of
advancement and it's not yeah we're not
we're not working in the mines at 12
years old and smoking heaters our whole
life anymore either man there is someone
alive today that will live
to be a thousand years old okay
it's extraordinary to me
that it's such an incredible incendiary
incendiary claim a thousand years old
kai what what is this
spoof of a site what's what
who is that independent someone's doing
it
independent
got it looks like a viagra commercial
there you go a thousand years i don't
know if that's gonna be happen by the
way if you're watching this if you're
watching this right now thumbs up
do you think
in our lifetime we're gonna see people
being able to live to 300 years old if
you're watching this yes no maybe
comment below do you think we're going
to see people getting to a number like
that obviously it's not going to happen
in our lifetime because that means we
need 200 more years for that to be
taking place but we're going to get to a
point where people are going to live
towards 200 would you want to live 300
years i think 300 is pushing it to be
honest with you i wouldn't mind like is
this funny is it still like until death
do us part do we got to do 270 years
together
that's when marriage becomes about term
limits
270 years
breaking a new generation
would you want to live 200 years
yeah i'd want to live forever honestly
how many years do i get to like actually
like
you know be functioning moving you know
what i mean like consume all of it would
you
want to live forever ah yeah i kind of
like i kind of like living gerard you
can only bench press 350 at the age of
140. would you do it yeah
how cool that is what do you think yes
no maybe
i don't know i don't think uh i don't
think i'd want to live forever
for sure but maybe
that's where i'd said that would you
want to live forever though but why not
why like what are you busy doing
something else i can't i i can't i can't
conceive of not living i can't conceive
all i've ever known i can't conceive of
of being anything other than this
consciousness living forever now i'm
good like the movie uh uh what is that
what age of adeline lightning strikes
you and your own age yeah you know and
you just you well the green mile i would
tell you i would tell you this i would
never want to live forever if the people
i love couldn't live forever as well
that's what exactly what i'm thinking
yeah i wouldn't watch
yeah if it's like everybody i don't know
i don't i don't know about that i don't
know about that why do you think they're
so concerned about population control
pat there's not gonna be enough room for
them they're gonna live for a thousand
years the plebeians gotta get out of the
way but i can see the the the the
powerful people who have all the money
in the world sitting behind closed doors
trying to find a solution sure on how
they can having the ability to do it i
mean look at kobe bryant when he wanted
to extend his career he'd go to germany
and have his blood spill you know you
can find all these technological
advances you can do and by the way do
you think elon musk loses credibility
when he talks about going to mars it
seems so preposterous so impossible and
yet he continues to drive at the fact
that he thinks it could happen wait wait
how is it preposterous it's it's a
matter of time to get there two years
it's a matter of time
you gotta also think we've taken you
tomorrow ten years ago to have rockets
that go up in the air and come down and
are fine was also insane yeah yeah so
everything he said he's going to do is
kind of
true that but what about the actual like
temperature on mine in fairness and
gravity in fairness elon musk said i
believe it was elon musk who said on
this very channel that giannis on
tacompulco would never win an nba final
you know what you need to you need to
pay closer attention to what i say go
back it's all documented on
valuetainment channels what i said well
that was you i thought that was
elaborate oh that's right he lost
credibility he stood by that thing
because i said if he continues to shoot
free throws like he has that was an
anomaly
17 out of 18 of the champions game okay
so man i was actually
i
it was an apple contract i didn't read
it i just clicked
let's let's wrap it up with uh federal
feds uh powell there is no returning to
pre-pandemic economy here we go again
all right so
ap news federal reserve chairman jerome
powell said tuesday that the u.s economy
has permanently changed by the kobe
pandemic and it's important that the
central bank adapt to those changes
those changes range from the increase in
remote work to restaurants offering more
takeout meals to real estate agents
learning how to show homes virtually he
noted many companies have already made
large investments in technology to adapt
to the challenges that the pandemic has
presented powell said the heavy
investment by companies and new
technology means that there will be more
jobs in the future associated with
maintaining that technology but also
potential job losses and industries
focus on in-person contact it seems a
near certainty that there will be
substantially more remote work going
forward
that's going to change the nature of
work and the way work gets done do you
agree no i don't and i think this is a
fad a cycle that we're going through i
don't think we can sustain the fact of
not going to the office i also you know
where's a little optimism where's a
little hope coming from our leaders
saying hey you know what we're on the
verge of this pandemic becoming an
endemic okay where we're going to be
able to live with it we're not going to
die we're going to survive yeah i i just
don't like the the messaging and i think
eventually once we pass you know this
cycle we're going through with high
inflation and maybe we get some
different leadership in there but no
don't make broad statements like that
when we just don't know
yeah interesting man um we kind of went
through something like this already with
the industrial revolution where society
kind of
sat stratified itself into urban and
agrarian you know and then it kind of
happened again after uh world war ii
when you had urban and suburban and it's
going to happen again now there are
people that are genuinely hate being
around other people that love
working at home that love wearing masks
and not having any human interaction and
it's going to be very difficult for them
to come back into society they don't
want to they never wanted to and then
there's other people like myself who i
need to be around other people i have to
be in social environments i go nuts when
i'm not and and i i realized about my
dad about myself in the last 18 months
i'm a very tribal guy i need to be part
of part of a crew and you're going to
have people that are doing that you're
going to have people that are going to
find environments where you have to be
social and they're going to be able to
find environments where they don't want
to be social but i also say look this is
the obama doctrine also when they're
talking about the economy it's more than
just the functionality of it i mean they
they tell you we're going to build back
better they've been straight up the
world economic forum has straight up
told you you will own nothing and be
happy and part of that that
that that
fine print that you're talking about
what they didn't tell us is that it's
because they're gonna own everything 3.5
trillion dollars in stimulus already the
greatest theft in the history of the
world they took 3.5 trillion of the
taxpayer dollars and made it their
dollars and what did we get for that
1200 bucks maybe some of us got 1200
bucks for 3.5 trillion then they're
going to get another trillion
only if we give them 3.5 trillion on top
of that so they already got four
trillion they're gonna get four and a
half trillion this is on top of the
eight years of quantitative easing from
obama the dollar is basically worthless
compared to was ten years ago and all of
that money is now their money they
figured out a way to make the entire
world sick and the way to heal everybody
it turns out was to make all of our
money
their money brilliant kai what do you
think about what powell said
i mean i think it's interesting uh it's
more of a long-term effect as well if
you look at kind of how things have
changed uh i think was you yuval harari
that said initially we read an article
back when we were still in dallas of how
a tremendous amount of change has
happened in a very short amount of time
uh and a lot of that can't necessarily
be reversed so i think there's
definitely more
long-term effects of this of what what
initially bounces back and then trends
or habits that have been changed
indefinitely so i think that'll kind of
play a big part as well moving on as we
go but then you also have uh like we saw
in the other article where retail
spending back to school is higher than
it's been
uh the last few years so there's kind of
things that are contradicting but i mean
we'll kind of see how things play out
yeah like you know you know it's crazy
when when you're saying this so okay
remember when everybody bought
newspapers how long ago was that
15 years 15 years ago guys when we
bought newspaper remember when everybody
at their house had a photo album how
long ago was that yeah
landline phone no when's the last time
we had actually photo albums at the
house
15 years ago 20 years ago right now
when's the last time we had landlines
how long was that 10 12 years by the way
if we did the percentage like if i could
pull up the data to find out how many
people don't have a home phone that they
use minutes i would love to see the
stats of minutes used on your home on
your home phone 20 years ago 30 years
ago two minutes being used
in the office you have to have it is
there a hard line here in the office on
the office
do we have a hardline phone here or no
yeah we do we actually do we actually do
but but if you ask me how many minutes
i've spoken to my home phone matter of
fact when is the last time you spoke on
a home phone
years
i haven't had one in 10 years kyle
when's the last time we spoke on home
phone
think about that 10 years how about when
you used to say i have to take this call
it's long distance yeah oh dude what
about when the the chord came out when
the extending chord came out you could
actually what about the call into this
like do you even have trouble so what
i'm trying to say is there's a part of
what he's saying is true like some
industries are going to change flat out
here's what we know we had sebastian
maniscalco at the event last week i'm
backstage and i'm having a conversation
together and i said hey sebastian how's
it been for you he says well i've been
doing a lot of zooms i said house it's
very different it's very weird just get
out there and you're trying to make
people laugh but you need a reaction
you're not really getting it but it is
what it is we're doing it people want to
do it and it's just like a conversation
that we have with them what's this
u.s
household uh telephone i'd want to go 20
more years back but that's interesting
right there from 2010
to 2016. look at that shift right there
68.2 29.7 to 50.8 45.9 but going back to
it some industries you have to be around
people are restaurants going to go out
of business no
not go out of business are they going to
be going away no i want to go to dinner
i want to go have a sit down have a
conversation with you right is there
going to be an opportunity disrupted yes
are movie theaters going to go away
yes if you kind of try to do the same
we've been doing it for 20 years so i
think there's going to be a lot of
disruption that takes place but i also
think some industries
are going to take a hit like you know
the whole story with 70
of fortune 500 companies from 1960 are
no longer around today yes of course
because today i send this a tweet i
don't know if i posted a tweet yesterday
or not
where i said things are changing so fast
the ability to adapt
and be able to predict how
human behavior is going to react to
something in the next 12 18 months
that's the formula
so so
how is how are we going to react
to the covet if somebody could have
predicted that 12
how are we going to react to this
stimulus if somebody could have known
you would have made the right investment
it's all about being able to predict it
not 100 but if somebody can do that and
make the adjustments because things are
changing very very fast today now let's
flip it are our people
gonna want to be to themselves and not
be around people i can't see that
happening i i can't see handshakes you
know when i go when i'm shaking hands
now i'm like okay how are you doing they
do the album
but but you know what we know what you
see is a lot of people right now just
shake hands i'm seeing like especially
in florida maybe not in california
california's like don't even get close
to me but people are shaking hands true
how are you doing i was in indiana i
went there and one guy comes up you know
the driver how you doing sir i'm like oh
i don't know you you don't know that's
cool shook his hands right so some of
this stuff i think
will go away but i think a lot of the
stuff that's the human interaction how
can a company thrive when people aren't
at the office especially big companies i
just think sure for a little while you
can adapt and make it happen but over
the long term i think people have to be
at the office by the way have you guys
seen the stories lately on the cottage
industry that's popped up lately with
people working from home it's people
holding two or three full-time jobs and
not letting the other companies know
about it having separate computers i
mean this is a big thing there's a big
online forum where people share ideas
and how they're getting away with did we
talk about that or no we haven't talked
about it on the add it to the story next
time yeah there are people that are
doing multiple full-time and that's why
they want to stay working at home and
how they dividing their time and making
changes
you know why it's not going to work long
term how long can you run a
uh how long can a con man keep coming
yeah double life man you just can't do
it there's a there's a time one little
thing will trip you up eventually house
of cards what's your next podcast via
tim sports tell us about okay so
valuetainment sports if you get a chance
check it out we launched this new
channel we're doing it today gerard's on
with me today always a great guest jeff
deutch is going to be on with me and you
know what pat we do topics that the
valuetainment audience loves i mean it's
not stats and nitty gritty sports stuff
it's gambling it's sports business today
we're talking about jerseys in the nhl
gonna have ads right we're talking about
jay-z opening up his own sports book
right we're talking about fighting have
you noticed how many fights there are
with fans in the stands right now and
they're violent i mean what is causing
this so it's a great conversation we're
gonna expand to this channel the raider
game which one well that was the ranch
that was the rams
beast yeah and i'm going um you guys
don't care about each other youtube fans
it's like the charger fans don't even
exist but someone threw a beer and it
was a lady yeah she threw a beer and
she's on tape too so if you get a chance
go to valuetainment sports subscribe and
you'll get our episodes and we're gonna
be adding a lot more content to it and
is adam doing the sauce talks money
today or no what time is sauce talks
money
four o'clock house four p.m
p.m having said that gang we are not
doing podcasts next week but others will
be episodes will be coming out but we
will do the podcast two weeks from now
on tuesday take care everybody bye bye
bye
you